hey everyone i am nicki wolf and this is
my glamour beauty spy
[Music]
so to start this look i am going to be
using the good apple foundation this is
the one that you guys have probably seen
has gone viral on tick tock it's such an
incredible full coverage medium to full
coverage foundation more suitable for
kind of normal to dry skin types but you
can wear it on oily skin types too with
the right primers and setting powders
it is available in 40 different shades
and you can see literally as that goes
on
how seamless and full coverage is i like
to apply the bulk of the product in the
center of the face and then kind of work
outwards that way you don't end up with
too much product in the hairline and you
get a really nice flawless even finish
you can use a sponge you can use your
fingers i personally like to use a brush
because i find i can be a bit more
precise that way i'm going to do now is
i'm just going to use a little bit of
the translucent lock-it setting powder
on a smaller brush this is a number five
brush and i'm just literally going to
press that in the center of the face in
the areas that we don't want to have too
much shine i'm also going to add a bit
of contouring and sculpting and a bit of
blush now the kvg contour palette is
literally like my best friend it goes
with me everywhere because these shades
work for pretty much every single skin
tone i'm using the lightest one now and
i'm just going to press that under eva's
cheekbones so the mod con gel blush is
literally like my new best friend it's
so gorgeous it gives you this beautiful
dewy skin like glow without any added
shimmer which makes it super flattering
it comes in four different shades i am
using shade glass cage on eva this is um
one of the deeper shades of the range
and the reason i'm using this is because
i feel like if you just use a tiny
amount of that product and really sort
of buff it into the skin then what you
get is almost like the effect of a stain
which means it's going to be long
wearing and give you a like really
lovely color payoff with just a tiny bit
of product this is where i use my
ultimate liner this is the kvd tattoo
liner so first of all i like to
um what i'm doing on myself or when i'm
doing it on someone else i always say
look down rather than close the eyes you
can always do it in little strokes
rather than one kind of full stroke
if you need to blink in between but i
just find that way if the eyes are open
then it means you get a nice smooth
fluid finish so what i've done so far is
i've literally just lined along the
length of uber's eyes this is the part
where i'm going to do the wing my little
tip for this is if you look straight
ahead
you want to be following the angle of
the bottom lash line so what i'm going
to do now is i'm just going to get you
to look down again and then bearing in
mind angle of her bottom lash line i'm
just going to bring that liquid liner up
and out
which i'm going to turn it to the side
you can see there and now that i've got
that shape in place this is where i'm
going to make it a little bit more thick
and dramatic
and fill in the gaps that is what i call
a killer liquid liner i mean there is a
reason why this is an award-winning
liquid liner what i'm going to do just
to finish that now is i'm going to bring
some of that liner down just in the
inner part of the eye so it really
continues to elongate the shape of the
eye
and i'm just really following the
natural kind of angles of his eyes to do
this i'm going to call this
liner because i just think it's so
fabulous to have that dramatic liquid
liner i'm going to finish this eye look
with the go big or go home mascara this
is a super super volumizing mascara you
can literally just tell from how chunky
that brush is it's going to give lots of
volume to the lashes and it lasts all
day which i love when you pull your
mascara out instead of wiping that
little bit you get on the end off of the
mascara i like to keep it the end of the
mascara and then actually use it
especially on the bottom lashes to
disperse product on the actual lash
and then once that product is on
they then use the kind of length of the
wand
to comb it through for the lips i'm
going to be using the everlasting liquid
lipstick this is super long wearing a
high pigment formula that just glides on
this is the most gorgeous kind of deep
plum
shade and i'm going to show you just how
much pigment and color payoff you can
literally see with one swipe
it gives you this super highly pigmented
and long wearing finish how incredible
is that amazing shade on eva i think it
works really well with the simplicity of
this cat eye my tip for creating the
perfect shape when you were doing such a
strong color like this on the lips is to
put the bulk of the color on with the
actual applicator and then use a little
brush just to kind of go around the
edges and that really helps you get a
nice neat precise finish
so here is our finished look
[Music]
i would say probably
um a graphic cat eye
or something like that definitely a
glowy skin and a full bushy brow
my most used beauty hack is probably to
apply individual lashes before mascara
and then put tons of mascara on
afterwards the best way i find to create
the glowiest kind of lip from within
skin is to highlight all of the kind of
high points of the face so rather than
quantity of product it's all about
careful product placement this is a
tricky question because i just think
makeup is all about just doing what
feels right to you and just
self-expression i think that only one
thing i could say is like the idea that
you have to follow
um
like a set routine like you know your
foundation goes on then your concealer
then your powder and then your blush and
you know whatever it is that's like that
kind of set routine maybe how some
people may have learned to do their
makeup i think they're the no-nos for me
i think we really need to break away
from that my instrument route to glamour
minutes has got to be a liquid liner i
mean you just can't beat the um
transformative effect of a liquid liner
how it can instantly change the shape of
your eye and just make you look more
polished the best beauty hack i think i
ever heard was from makeup artist terry
barber i saw him do a demo years and
years and years ago and i remember in
this demo he was doing mascara and he
said if you don't get a blob of mascara
on the skin then you probably haven't
applied enough my curly hair must-have
is my l'oreal mousse
there's just this l'oreal volume mousse
that i have used for years and years
and doesn't matter what i try i always
go back to this l'oreal volume mousse my
biggest personal beauty indulgence is
candles i don't know whether you can
cast that as beauty it's kind of like
beauty and self-care candles at least to
me it is um but i have literally a
candle obsession i have so many candles
cast oil
sounds really random but castor oil is
just really handy
kind of all-around moisturizer and
really nice to apply on your lashes and
brows to keep them conditioned
especially after wearing makeup my musty
beauty ritual is to take my makeup off i
just
cannot sleep with my makeup on overnight
and then i can go to bed in peace
feeling like i've done something good
for my skin i
have this like mild ocd with filing my
nails it doesn't matter
which manicurist i see or how incredible
they are and i'm sure it drives a lot of
them up the wall but i just have to file
my own nails my favorite ones at the
moment
uh what am i wearing today i am wearing
baccarat rouge and then i have layered
that with
um
a fragrance called
fleur narcotic
i would say the secret to getting the
perfect beauty shot is all about
lighting lighting is literally key um
and it can really make the difference
between a shop being gorgeous and not
gorgeous
[Music]
i am going to talk you through some of
my most loved products at the moment for
skin hair and makeup too um let's start
with skin cleansers that i'm absolutely
loving at the moment are this cladopo
cream cleansing oil this is so
incredible because you can just use this
one product to cleanse i'm a big fan of
double cleansing i think it's really
important to be able to remove all your
makeup any debris from the day and spf
especially sometimes can be hard to
remove from the skin and this takes off
absolutely everything and then to follow
that
in the evenings i will use um a serum
followed by a moisturizer and my main
goal is just to give my skin as much
hydration as possible because it's quite
dry then in the daytime all about
vitamin c and spf so i'll always use a
serum with vitamin c i've been using
vitamin c on my skin for years i've
suffered with pigmentation and melasma
and i find vitamin c really helps to
improve and just brighten the skin
and
you know give you the best glow let me
talk you through some foundations that
i'm loving at the moment um
there is this new one from valentino
valentino beauty has recently launched
and they're very valentino long-lasting
foundation is so beautiful i use shade
mn2 and i really love the texture of
this one i find it's lightweight gives a
glow but not too too glossy that it's
going to slide off another one that i
love and it's been like a favorite for
so many years is the estee lauder double
wear stay in place this i use when i
want a little bit more of a matte finish
super super long wearing double wear
another foundation i love is the kvd
good apple foundation
um this is one of those foundations
that's really unique because it's super
full coverage and creamy but the
beautiful thing about this is it still
like retains that gorgeous dewyness on
the skin so this is what i'll use when i
feel like i have a little bit extra
coverage but i want to keep my skin
still looking hydrated and dewy then
onto mascara and there's a few that i'm
loving at the moment um the girl and mad
eyes mascara is really great if you want
full volumized lashes then onto brows
um at the moment i kind of switch
between two products for my brows one is
the new valentina beauty brow trio
and the other is the estee lauder
featherlite brow enhancer
i've got to be honest the reason that i
use these is exactly the same for both
they've got a really fine applicator
that allows you to kind of draw in these
super fine hair like strokes both shades
are exactly right for my brows the estee
lauder one is in shade black and the
valentino one is in shade granite
and i just kind of elongate the ends of
my brows my brows are really thick and
and dense naturally but i just like to
make them a little longer and lifted at
the tips i generally like to keep my
lips pretty natural
i always use this liner this has got to
be
my most favorite nude of all time and
that is quite a statement it's just
like a perfect nude it's just a pinky
naturally roundy nudey kind of
easy to wear looks like your lips suits
absolutely everyone from like the fairer
skin
even to like
deep much deeper than me and then
lipstick-wise the moment i'm loving the
k really
epic kiss lipstick look how gorgeous
that packaging is really easy to wear
they've got a slightly glossy finish
which makes them um easy to wear and
comfortable and hydrating also i'm
really liking this one from bare
minerals
this is a lipstick in the shade grace
just a really pretty kind of pinky
peachy
little satin satin
so that is nice and also a little bit
more matte so when i want something more
natural then that's a great one and then
i'm just obsessed with lip balm i have
so many lip balms it's ridiculous my
favorite lip balm of all time
is the sensei lip treatment
more of a lip treatment than a lip balm
and i use this at night rather than in
the day because it's like a cream um but
it's so deeply hydrating so if you are
one of these people that has lips that
just never seem to be hydrated no matter
what you apply this is the one for you
hairwise is pretty much the same i just
like to give my hair lots and lots of
moisture and then for styling i use all
different things on the kind of mid
length but what i use on the roots and
the ends of my hair has remained the
same for years and years and years i um
use the l'oreal um
full volume extra mousse
which is really really volumizing quite
a stronghold i just put it in the roots
of my hair because it gives great root
lift so there you have it there was my
glamour beauty spy so thank you all for
watching i hope you have enjoyed sending
you
lots of love and kisses and i'll see you
soon
you